l'histoire si
[Musique]
45 ans séparent ces deux images ici on
l'appelait le câble ce téléphérique met
en place son 19e pour soulager les
hommes dans cette reculer jurassienne
l'élevage se faisait en eau dans les
amours et le fromage en bas
le fameux guyanais qui
agrémentait notre paysage
au niveau du 19e et du début du xxème
donc notre téléphérique les producteurs
du plateau
jusqu'à fin avant 1893 descendez le lait
par des sentiers escarpés lokeren et des
risques dans toute saison à l'occasion
des deux traites de la journée et puis
donc
un des producteurs avait fait son
service militaire du côté de grenoble et
qui avait
remarqué quand on exploitait les
carrières de l'osé quand les transporter
par ce système le jeune homme imagine
alors qu'on peut faire la même chose
avec les bouilles à l'est et comme il se
trouve qu'il est aussi président de la
société fromagère de blois il confie la
réalisation de l'ouvragé à une petite
entreprise jurassienne nous sommes en
le principe est simple il fonctionne par
l'invité donc le panier plein au plateau
faisant monter le panier vide
aucune source d'énergie
le câble fonctionnera jusqu'en 1982 date
de la fermeture de la fromagerie à toucy
s'il évoque des souvenirs indélébiles
depuis ces images de 1977 où l'on voit
en action les derniers fromage et du
village
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui allaient
chercher le lait à la fromagerie quand
le téléphérique descendait arrivé à la
fromagerie c'est vrai que c'était quand
même une attraction déjà à l'époque très
agréable quand le lait arrive et le
fromager était là qui récupère lé
bouille il y avait un système de cornes
pour se compléter avec ceux du hameau
qui mettait en place qu'ils étaient en
couple et et les cours
depuis le siège du voyage du voyage
arrivées et puis quand il arrivait en
bas et ben je déchargeais il est 10
heures et toujours à ben j'en ai bavé la
première année parce qu'il y en a qui
mettait des pyramides et une bouille de
50 litres mais en fait une grosse
brouille alors il y avait plus de 60 kg
l'été il faisait 2 2 voyage ce n'est pas
tout alors que je vais comme c'est lé
plein qui remonte elle évite alors au
deuxième voyage j'avais la trompette
jetons pétait et puis à l'époque ça
repartait deuxième voyage arrivées des
fois ça marchait pas oui oui oui comme
l'hiver que tu avais du givre sur les
balais les bouilles elle restée elle
restait la nuit puis le lendemain
ça risquait rien puisqu'il était au
froid il est oui
depuis la fin de la fabrication du comté
en 82 le téléphérique est resté en gare
mais la maire de l'époque et les anciens
n'imaginez pas le voir disparaître il
aura fallu pour trouver enfin les fonds
nécessaires à sa restauration qu'un
amoureux d'histoire locale découvre le
village à l'occasion d'une balade en
vélo et contacter la fondation du
patrimoine
non on va essayer de revenir au
téléphérique de 1893 dans son
fonctionnement initial donc une vraie
marque de respect aussi voilà un respect
pour nos anciens qui à l'époque ont fait
un travail formidable on est admiratif
fonctionnement comment ils ont pu amener
ces câbles jusqu'en haut voilà financer
un projet de ce type
aujourd'hui ces cent mille euros qu'il a
fallu réunir pour sauver le plus ancien
téléphérique français